hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
steam MC control
ac.l2-3.1.5 employ the principle of
least privilege including for specific
security functions and privileged
accounts
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance hero alright let's
jump into it in an ideal and secure
world you should only be able to do what
you're allowed to do and nothing else
or you go to jail no the goal of cmmc
control ac.l2-3.1.4
employee principle of least privilege
including for specific security
functions and privileged accounts is to
absolutely limit
authorize users to only be being able to
do the things which are required to
complete their required job duties any
further access or capability is simply
no bueno not allowed not necessary and
because of that being able to do what is
not necessary brings about a higher
level of security access and risk to
information than necessary in essence
this is the first control we really
begin to see the necessity of real true
risk management coming into play with
cmmc now if I was an assessor there's
three points that I would be assessing
on okay the first one is I would
determine if privileged accounts are
identified in other words is there some
way to figure out that this account has
more privileges or is privileged versus
a standard user account if I was to give
a sample answer I would say something
like privileged accounts or identify
within active directory and privileged
identity management if you're using like
an Azure uh privileged identity
management service there's a lot of
answers uh you know to how you could
answer that but that's maybe one of the
simpler ones now determinive access to
privileged accounts is authorized in
accordance with principal of Lee's
privilege uh again the idea there being
hey do you get just the least amount of
privilege that you need to do your job
uh and if I was to give a sample answer
there I would say privileged accounts
are only granted based upon requirement
of assigned job duties access to
privileged accounts is only authorized
through the it ticketing system by the
organization's I don't know chief
operations officer or uh you know
whoever the information system owner is
there's got to be some Authority on who
gets access and there needs to be some
sort of chain of command there
assessment point would be determining if
security functions are actually defined
so if I was going to Define security
functions I would say hey security
functions are identified uh via the
entitlement lifecycle management process
and access reviews now if you're not
familiar with entitlement lifecycle
management you can Google it it's a
Microsoft thing now that was the answer
you know that we kind of came up with
for this little sample equation here but
there's lots and lots of ways to do this
right so determining if security
functions are identified again it could
be a written policy it could be you know
looking perhaps maybe at the way that
active directory is structured do you
have different security groups you know
with definitions on the security groups
and active directory and then the access
reviews part is hey is somebody
periodically reviewing what's going on
with say active directory in that
example and actually seeing that those
people only have the access that they
need that if you can show all that that
is when you'll pass this control and
make sure that you're uh that you've met
your requirements now if you're
scratching your head if uh if you're
scratching other body parts I can't help
you there but uh and on call what I can
tell you is we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this D fars nist itar and cmmc compliant
stuff dropping their laugh like a
seagull on a sunny day we teach you how
to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you and it probably won't really
actually solve you from being itchy but
if you're looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit
cmmccomplianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
like really please help us out help us
out with a big thumbs up on that like
button just go ahead and hit it right
now for even better smash the Subscribe
button baby all right we got hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of subscribers
and we're trying to get hundreds and
hundreds and thousands more hey you know
what we put this stuff out here for free
and if it helped you we'd love a little
subscribe love it really helps us out uh
again to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance Center
is rolling out uh until the next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there and only as secure as
you're allowed to be uh and hit us in
the comments below to let us know what
you'd like to know more about when it
comes to information security and
compliance and you know what I'll see
you on the next one
[Music]